what Dell Cameron is doing here this
wired reporter is basically saying we
will be the the information laundering
service for those that want to destroy
your life and harass and intimidate and
cause you harm
so Matt Walsh who clearly has
ideological enemies will seek out the
the enemies will seek out any means by
which they can cause damage to him and
this is quote unquote journalists the
great irony of this is the journals who
I think very few people on the right
have any respect for anymore but but
they're they're understanding what
you've pointed out Tim which is that
they just work with these political
operatives but the journalists always
present themselves as the brave fourth
estate speaking truth to power on the
front lines and the irony here is Nat
Walsh is actually one of the most
important journalists in America right
Matt Walsh is doing much more important
journalistic work than any of these
people at any of these liberal
Publications